(loud whooshing)
- What's up Believe Nation?
I started the Mentor
Me series with the goal
to try to learn from people
who've done a lot more than us,
hang around them a little bit longer,
and by being in their environment,
hopefully some of their
mindsets, their beliefs,
their way of thinking, seep into us,
to help us become the
best version of ourselves.
So today we're going to
learn from Jim Carrey
on staying motivated.
Mentor me Jim.
And as always guys, as
you're watching the clip,
if you hear something that
really really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired,
and also when you write it
down you're much more likely
to lock it in for yourself too.
Enjoy.
(inspiring music)
- [Narrator] Silliness
has been with Jim Carrey
since he was a baby.
Born, with a crooked hat.
His face has never failed to get a laugh,
at family parties or at
school, where he says,
being the class clown
helped him to make friends.
But Jim dropped out of school
in grade nine to mold his act.
Two years later, his first TV appearance.
The impressions were there,
but the nuances weren't.
- Thank you very much.
My name is Jimmy Carter.
And I am the president of
the United States of America.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
- [Narrator] Though the
nuances are here now.
They did not come easily.
- And I used to be--
- [Narrator] Jim struggled,
trying to perfect his impressions.
He usually performed at a
popular comedy club in Toronto.
- I used to drive like
50 miles back and forth
from Jackson's Point every
second night or every night,
to do a set at Yuk Yuk's for free.
No pay.
Ooh!
Not even a gas stub or anything, nothing.
And uh I used to do that and
did that for the longest time
just kept working until
people started to take notice,
you know, and, and the rest was history.
- At one point, or not at one point,
'cause I hear you still do,
you would be in front of a
mirror and just make faces
all the time.
- Yeah.
For me it was so much fun
to me to sit in my room
and make faces and talk to
myself in different voices
and things and I'd go.
Looks like Sammy.
It is like Sammy you know.
Yeah he does that, you know.
I'd just sit for hours doing that
and my parents were so
worried they would, you know,
they would say, you know,
my mother tried to scare me
with the spiritual thing, you know.
Just like if you don't stop doing that
you're going to see the devil.
You know that kind of thing.
And I, of course that
just made me do it more.
I mean I got a lot of
support from my parents.
That's the one thing that I
always appreciated was that
they didn't tell me I was being stupid,
they told me I was being funny.
- [Interviewer] Uh huh.
- That was the difference.
- When you were 15
your father took you to
a comedy club to perform.
- My mother dresses me
in a polyester suit,
tells me, you know, this is
what all the boys are wearing.
And sends me down there.
My father helped me write my act.
And I went down to the comedy club
and the owner of the club
had this little thing
that he liked to do where he would
stand backstage with a microphone
and all kinds of fun effects.
And you know, heckle new comedians.
And so when I got up there
it was just horrendous,
he was like backstage going,
totally boring, totally
boring, totally boring.
They were playing, you know, excerpts from
Jesus Christ Superstar like, you know,
crucify him, crucify him,
crucify him, that kind of thing.
So, you know, when you go through
a few of those experiences
you kind of develop a thick skin
when it comes to being
ridiculed or whatever.
- Why didn't you give it up?
- I couldn't I mean, I don't have a trade.
(laughing)
This is my spot.
This is the center of the universe.
This is where I hang out
with Buddha and Krishna and,
you know, all those guys.
- Are you a Buddhist?
- Jesus.
I'm a Buddhist, I'm a
Muslim, I'm a Christian,
I'm whatever you want me to be.
You know it all comes
down to the same thing.
You're in a loving place or
you're in an unloving place.
If you are with me right
now, you cannot be unhappy.
It's not possible.
Just try.
- [Interviewer] His faith
his personal and mystical.
He believes that miracles will come true,
if you just believe in them.
And he has his life and
his career to prove it.
But he does think that people
who express strong feelings
about spirituality, run the
risk of being labeled a kook.
- You know, what the hell.
What the hell, you know, whatever.
I just want to be myself.
If I lose a few fringe people
who can't deal with the fact
that, you know, that there's
other forces in the world,
that's okay with me.
When I was a kid, I
brought relief to my family
by taking their painful concerns
and alchemizing them into comedy.
And they enjoyed watching
me play, most of the time.
Later my career in show business blossomed
after I made the conscious
decision to serve the audience
what I thought they really needed to see.
Someone who's carefree in the world,
and treats it all with a
healthy doth of irreverenth.
Yeth, thath how I meanth to say it.
Since very early in my memory,
the real thrill in my life
wasn't personal recognition,
as much as knowing that
I could affect people
in a positive way and have fun doing it.
Before I had money I used
to write have a nice day
on $20 bills and leave them
where I knew people in need
would find them.
I didn't wait around to see their smiles
I just was satisfied knowing
that for one brief moment
they might feel a little bit lucky.
As time passed my interest in
people's welfare has grown,
but for me living in this
world will always be a game,
the object of which is to create
as much goodwill as possible.
I realize now, more than ever,
that the most valuable commodity in life,
is the feeling you get when you give.
Compassion is the currency
that leads to true wealth.
I created Better U so I
could continue to expand
my awareness of what people need,
to relieve or prevent
suffering wherever possible.
And to offer a kind of
assistance that allows people
to grow towards independence
and self-actualization.
And a healthy doth of irrevernth.
A Better U means a better universe.
Anything that doesn't work out.
Any show that I might not get.
Any show that I might do
that doesn't turn out well
and gets pulled off or
something like that,
I always think of as this is
the way it was supposed to be,
that's the way it was supposed to happen,
because there's something
bigger down the road.
There's something better down the road
and this is happening because
I'm not ready or, you know,
and it's always happened that way.
I mean the first time I
ever went to Yuk Yuk's
when I was 15 years old,
I went to Church Street.
The old Yuk Yuk's it was two
lanes of a bowling alley.
And I went there and I was not good.
(laughing)
I was all right, I mean I was--
- You were 15.
- I was 15, I had a
white polyester suit on,
my mum put on me and I
went down there with Dad
and got up on stage and I
was doing all right really.
But the owner of the club
got on the mike backstage
and started going totally boring,
and all of sudden it
wasn't hip enough for them,
so I was pretty shattered
and I didn't go back
for two years.
And then my father said, when I was 17,
I started doing little
shows here and there again.
And he said when don't
you go back to Yuk Yuk's.
I said, no way, I don't
want to go back there.
And he said well you really, you know,
you should get over it.
I mean if you're going
to go into the business
and you want to do it seriously
you can't have those barriers, you know.
And I went back and I did
great and I became a regular
and a headliner and it built from there,
and then when I went down to Los Angeles
the same thing happened.
I went to the Comedy
Store, I did all right,
but not good enough to become a regular.
And I became totally discouraged
with the Comedy Store.
I came back to Toronto
like everybody who
doesn't do well down there
comes back going, I hate Los Angeles.
It's such a crummy place.
No really, you can't raise
kids there, and all that stuff.
And, Comedy Store is a
rat race, it's a rat race.
(laughing)
But then two years later,
again, my father, he says to me,
well you should try and
get in to the Comedy Store.
And my manager set up a showcase there,
I went in and I did well
and became a regular there,
and everything has
happened from there since.
It's just, it's been incredible,
and it always goes in stages like that.
So I accept the fact
that I fail, you know,
because I know that it's, that's the way
it's supposed to be.
I have no education.
I had no high school diploma.
I didn't even have a GED.
I quit high school and,
halfway through grade ten.
I didn't have a lot of options.
I would be a dishwasher, a waiter.
Custodial work of some sort.
So I decided I might as well
go and do something creative.
I decided to go to the Comedy
Store, the Laugh Factory
and the improv, you know,
all of those clubs every night,
and make my 25 bucks a pop, a set.
It was my version of being a waiter.
It was a compromise I decided to make.
Out of that came In Living Color,
and out of that came touring
auditoriums, 5000 seaters.
It was a really creative time.
I was able to prove
that I didn't have to be an impressionist.
That I had a personality of my own and,
however abrasive it might
be from time to time.
But long story short, all of
it came from that compromise,
from that deciding to do
what I didn't want to do.
Things you can't do,
or the things you're not allowed to do.
Like if the executives come
and say you can't do that,
whatever it is, it's too
expensive, you get angry,
you get out of your mind about it,
because you've been clinging
to this concept and this image
that you have of how it should be done.
Invariably, most times,
after that storm has passed,
and you actually sit down and go okay,
we can't do it that way, how can we do it,
you end up with something even better
than what was there before.
And you go, that's the
universe, that's how it works.
Just like relationships, like everything.
The thing that is taken away,
that you're clinging to,
you're trying to fix,
you're trying to secure it,
make sure it doesn't go away.
You think that your
life will be destroyed,
everything will be ruined.
And it's just the universe going no,
I have something better for you.
Just have faith.
Sometimes compromise is actually the way
to get to what you want.
Doing what you don't want is
the way to what you do want.
On occasion.
I would never have made it
without going back and doing
what I didn't want to do.
- Jim I wanted to ask you, some years ago,
you wrote yourself a check.
- Yes I did.
I guess it's like six,
seven years ago now.
I wrote a check out to
myself for $10 million
for acting services rendered--
- [Interviewer] In 1995.
- By Thanksgiving 1995.
And I put it in my wallet and I carried it
for that many years.
And what happened was
basically, a few months ago,
we did the deal for the
The Mask for $10 million.
- $10 million payment for doing The Mask.
- Right.
Payment for doing The Mask too.
And so it's very surreal
for me it's strange.
And I used to go up to
Mulholland Drive every night,
sit on the side of the road,
look out at the lights,
and go, you know, I'm a popular actor.
I'm a, you know, every
director wants to work with me.
And I used to like open my
arms and imagine things,
you know, things that I wanted
coming my way and stuff.
And what I would do, it was a
way of dealing with, you know,
being completely out of work.
I would stay up there
until I actually believed
that I had all these things.
And then I would drive down
the mountain feeling like
the biggest star in Hollywood.
Like I was working all the time,
like the best people
wanted to work with me.
And I had my thing in my pocket,
my little check in my pocket.
You know it's our intention.
Our intention is everything.
Nothing happens on this planet without it.
Not one single thing has
ever been accomplished
without intention.
So I started thinking about my life
and I started thinking
about this conference,
and what we're about and I
looked back and I thought, well,
I was two people.
My whole life I was in the
living room entertaining people,
being a monkey.
(making monkey noises)
You know doing my thing
for the company and,
and trying to relieve my
mother who was suffering.
She had rheumatoid
arthritis and phlebitis,
and everything under the
sun that was nagging at her,
and she was depressed, and
I wanted her to be free.
And I wanted her to realize that
her life was worth something
'cause she'd gave birth to
someone who's worth something.
And then I would go into
my room and I would sit
with a legal pad.
(laughing)
I was a little kid.
And I would sit there and
I would try to figure out
what it meant, what it was all about.
Why are we here?
What is this?
And one day I read something
from Buddha that said
that all spirituality is
about relieving suffering.
And I suddenly realized,
that's what I'm doing in the other room.
(laughing)
And I'm aligned.
You know this, my purpose
is aligned with this.
So I felt incredibly lucky.
I lose sight of that all the time.
I get caught up in different
concerns and ego concerns.
But I'm so lucky to be
a part of this community
and to do something that is of value.
And I really cherish that
and we are all one thing,
it really is true.
Now fear is going to be
a player in your life.
But you get to decide how much.
You can spend your whole
life imaging ghosts,
worrying about the pathway to the future.
But all there will ever be
is what's happening here,
and the decisions we make in this moment,
which are based in either love or fear.
So many of us choose our path out of fear
disguised as practicality.
What we really want seems
impossibly out of reach
and ridiculous to expect
so we never dare to ask
the universe for it.
I'm saying, I'm the proof
that you can ask the universe for it.
My father could've been a great comedian
but he didn't believe that
that was possible for him.
And so he made a conservative choice.
Instead he got a safe
job as an accountant.
And when I was 12 years old
he was let go from that safe job,
and our family had to do
whatever we could to survive.
I learned many great
lessons from my father,
not the least of which
was that you can fail
at what you don't want, so you
might as well take a chance
on doing what you love.
(cheering and applauding)
- So thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know what did
you learn from this video?
What clips spoke to you the most,
and what are going to
take from these clips
and immediately apply to your life
or to your business somehow.
Leave it down in the comments below,
I'm super-curious to find out.
Finally I want to give a quick
shout-out to Inside Junky.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and making
that awesome YouTube video
on it as well.
I'm really really glad
that you enjoyed the book
and I appreciate your support.
- [Narrator] If you knew
how to start your business,
or how to make more money, this
book may just be the answer
that you're looking for.
Today we're talking about Your
One Word by Evan Carmichael.
- So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
(loud whooshing)